I want to talk to you about your morning
routine does this support you does it
build you up does it help you go out and
believe in yourself
I want to go make the world a better
place or are you like most people and
you wake up in the morning and you're
frantic and rushing and trying to cram
everything else in there and you're
you're frantically trying to get to work
get your schools and your kids to school
rush off to whatever meeting your
morning sets the tone for your entire
day and you want to have a routine that
builds you up that gives you confidence
and that set you on the path to go out
and have an amazing day so today I'm
going to share with you seven morning
routines for business and personal
success number one is start preparing
the night before most people have great
morning routines they start the night
before when you actually have a little
bit more time so instead of trying to
cram everything in to that hectic
ridiculously crazy morning help make it
easier for yourself by planning a little
bit more than night before so if you're
one of your goals is to exercise them to
run more the night before set up your
shoes set up your exercise gear set up
your clothes so that all you have to do
is wake up and put them on if one of
your goals is to eat healthier and
you're tired of going out and eating
McDonald's for lunch or whatever it is
then the night before plan your lunch
make a sandwich make a salad create
something healthy have some snacks you
can just go to the fridge pull out your
bag and you're off to work today is my
video day when I know it's my video we
did the night before I set up my camera
I said up my gear so that my microphone
is all ready for me to go so all I have
to do is walk in and press record and
I'm ready to go make it easy for
yourself don't cram more into your
morning prepare the night before
number two is have a family moment if
you have a family if you have husbands
or wife and some kids you know how
ridiculously crazy it is in the morning
to get everybody off to where they're
supposed to be in the midst of all that
chaos
try to find some time to have a quick
family moment something quick something
fun something easy something just to let
people feel loved and to let you feel
loved because again if you're just
rushing off and you're you're short with
the other person and you're getting on
each other's nerves that's not the way
to start a day so for me I usually wake
up after my wife has already left the
house she works early and she's out of
the house early and I wake up after
she's already gone but the first thing
that I do when I wake up is I grab my
phone and I load up my facebook
Messenger app that I know she has open
and I send her a little character little
cartoon maybe it's a dog blowing a heart
maybe it's a penguin a little costume
something cute just to let her know that
I'm thinking of her and that I love her
if I wake up and she's still here then
I'll try to do something to help her
with her morning routine so there's a
vitamin drink that she likes to drink in
the morning I might help her make that
if she hasn't made her her breakfast it
hasn't had time to eat it I help make
that for her whatever I can do to help
make her morning go a little bit more
smoothly show her a little bit of love
go to the door give her a hug if she's
taking off because it makes her feel
great it gives her better start to the
day and it also makes me feel great it
doesn't have to be complicated just
something simple something fun something
cute something that that is loving in
the morning for the special person in
your life to help both of you start off
on the right foot
number three turn on music music is like
a drug right when the right song comes
on you're bouncing you're moving you're
dancing you know you're you're bobbing
your head it gives you energy right so
you want to start the day off with that
you don't want to wait till after lunch
before you get energy if you're off to
do something important right we're off
trying to change the world make the
world a better place for ourselves our
family our kids our community everybody
make it a better place to live right
that's what we're all trying to do you
need energy to do that and music starts
you off on the right tone so make a
playlist I have a playlist called the
belief playlist no surprise and it's all
songs that I love hearing that when it
comes on and makes me want to dance it
makes me want to groove it makes me want
to get up get out of my chair and
and move around and you need that in the
morning because you can't just wake up
and go through your day like this until
eventually wake up after lunch so find
your favorite songs make a list of 20
different songs that you can put on
random and after you wake up you put it
on and you start moving so turn on music
number four have a lemon water you are
dehydrated when you wake up okay you
haven't had water for whatever number of
hours you are sleeping and your body
sweats while you sleeps you lose water
you are dehydrated and you need water to
give you energy if you wake up on your
sluggish the number one reason is going
to be not enough sleep but the number
two reason is you don't have enough
water in you so go get some water I like
to fill it with lemon because it has a
whole bunch of properties in there that
they help you and give you energy when
I'm doing these videos I have a glass of
lemon water with me and it gives you
energy so you can even set this up the
night before if you want glass of water
puts the lemon juice in it and start
your day every day with that routine
number five was workout if you are
trying to have a healthy lifestyle if
you want to build a workout into your
daily routine the easiest way to do it
is in the morning because if you try to
schedule stuff in the afternoon in the
evening often you'll find your day
explodes on you emergencies come up you
don't have time to go or you're so
exhausted from your day that you say oh
I'm not going to do it today I'll do it
some other time and that some other time
never happens so if you want something
to happen on a daily basis or on a
regular basis your plan for it in the
morning
so we've already set up our shoes and
our clothes in our gear the night before
we're ready to go and working out even
if it's for 15 minutes 20 minutes in the
morning something quick doesn't have to
be a two hour marathon workout it gets
your body moving just like music gets
you moving a little bit
so does working out and if you're you're
pumping weights or if you are you know
doing some cardio whatever it is moving
your body getting energy getting
activity getting motion gives
you momentum to go out and do something
great I get a lot of great ideas when
I'm working out I get a lot of great
ideas in the shower after working out
and after I've finished a workout I feel
refreshed energized ready to go out and
tackle my day and way more energy than I
get if I don't if I miss a workout
because I've got a really early morning
you know conference call or your arm off
speaking at some event then I feel
sluggish it's harder to get started so
get some workout time scheduled in there
again like 15 minutes in the morning
just to get your body moving
number six is remember your Y remember
why you're starting this remember why
you're doing your business what are you
doing this for who is it for right is it
for yourself for your family for your
your your kids for your community why
are you doing this why is this so
important you need to have a really
important really powerful why because
what often happens is you know you may
be working and and something happens you
remember your wife remember your kids
you remember there's this dream goal
that you have that you want to go and
accomplish and maybe that happens in
like 3:00 in the afternoon and then you
oh yeah I'm now I'm all motivate and
ready to go I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
kill it here we go rah rah yes and then
you go on the rest of the days awesome
and then you go to bed and you wake up
next day and it's gone like where was
that momentum what happened it's all
it's it's totally gone so you want to
schedule that in and you want to start
the day with it to give you energy for
the entire day so remember why you're
doing is if you're just doing it for
money it's not going to work out it's
not gonna it's not going to be this big
thing you have to stand for something
way more important and if you look at
famous entrepreneur I they got started
it wasn't just trying to make a lot of
money it was trying to make something
better right so what is your big why and
remind yourself of that every day when
you look at that it should give you
excitement it should give you motivation
should give you energy I want to help a
billion entrepreneurs through my website
a billion on
is going to take a long time but it's
something that motivates me I love
helping entrepreneurs I believe in
entrepreneurs it fuels me when I see
that I'm ready to go I'm ready to take
action ready to start making these
videos and we're going to answer your
emails I'm ready to launch big scary
projects and you want that every morning
you want to schedule that into your
environment so that you set yourself up
for success that day and number seven is
do a task that gives you energy so after
I've looked at my big why the next thing
I do and I call these my little why's is
I look at my YouTube comments
every morning I eat my lentils and I
look at my YouTube comments because you
guys give me energy and you want to do a
task that gives you energy that makes
you remember why you're doing is because
sometimes that big why you can seem too
big and too scary and so the little why
those little tasks that you do they give
you energy help keep you grounded helps
show the momentum when you guys leave
comments on my videos it makes me feel
like I'm doing something important right
it makes me it gives me a great reminder
of what I'm doing and gives me energy
and confidence and courage to keep going
in the try new things so you guys are my
little why you guys are the tasks that
gives me energy every morning so I love
watching what you're posting so post
comments below guys because they're
really important but before I did that
before I had as many YouTube comments
I'm fortunate now that there's comments
that come on every video before that
happened I would make a PowerPoint file
and I would watch it every day and
inside the file would be comments that
customers had left or comments of people
if I went and did a presentation at a
YMCA and there were five people there in
the room and you know they all left
great comments I would take that comment
and put it up on my screen because maybe
I'm only doing one presentation a month
because I'm just getting started but
seeing those things seen those comments
gives me the courage and the motivation
to keep going so if you don't have a
daily have something that you do that
reminds you of the importance of the
work that you're doing and get
encouragement and feedback and momentum
to help you grow your business
so in summary seven morning routines for
business and personal success number one
start preparing the night before number
two have a family moment number three
turn on music number four lemon water
number five workout number six remember
your why and number seven do a task that
gives you energy and believe if you guys
like this video you want to see more
just like it you can subscribe to the
channel and thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon and then I
roll back see that's what happens when
you take a little bit of time to make
someone feel special in the morning if
you want more believe energy running
through your veins sign up for the
newsletter below it's free you're gonna
love it
hi I'm Jason G respond so you got a rose
online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring XD only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period